- I'm asking for complete
honesty now. No liars involved.
When you do a production,
you become a second family.
That means family secrets, so
it's time to get those out.
Here we go!
I'm going to direct these
questions at Lin Manuel
and the rest of you should feel free
to confirm what he says
or plead the fifth.
So Lin, of your original cast,
who is most likely to
curse when blowing a line?
So who am I friends with, basically?
- Man, Leslie had a flame
out in the first preview
but he went, "Ah shoot."
He didn't curse.
- [Oak] Did not curse.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- All of these guys are pretty much pros.
Christopher will curse the most backstage
after messing up on stage.
- [Kelly] I'm like, Oh my god.
I feel like such a bad human
- But he will never do that on stage.
- Well they don't have, you
don't have to be like angry
like, some people just
- If my momma has something
to say about that,
I'm coming to find you, homie.
- I will call Jane. I
will make things okay.
- [Leslie] Wow, self-plug okay.
- Okay, okay.
Okay, Lin, who was in charge of getting
the dance party started backstage?
I love that there were dance parties.
- Oh that's a combo of
probably Renee and Oak.
- Ayyyy!
- I know there's whole,
there's whole sections
of the backstage traffic
I never saw 'cause I was on-stage.
But they were responsible
for bring to life.
I would look over and be like,
"What's happening stage right?"
And Oak is like.
- It's true.
That is a true statement.
- [Christopher] Didn't
Leslie host the dance party?
- [Daveed] Leslie, hosted yeah.
- [Lin] Oh, yes, and Leslie
hosted. That was a tradition.
I was thinking during the show.
- When did we do it, well
there was a point where
- But yes, he had special speakers.
- He did
- I remember that, yeah.
- That happened at intermission
- There was intermission
one night a week though
was a Friday. It was
like Saturday or Friday?
- [Daveed] I can't remember
but I looked forward to it.
- I think it was like, last
two show day of the week
we would do intermission.
We would do like, energy up
- [Lin] But then aftershow,
Daveed and his buddy,
Rafa, started doing drinks out the Grammy
when we won the Grammy.
So after that they
- [Leslie] Shot out the Grammy!
- [Lin] Took shot out of the Grammy award.
So that was the post-show,
after-after party.
- Yeah, that was post the after party.
- That's so cool! I want to-
so wait, who is most likely to whisper
side conversations in
the middle of scene, Lin?
- Oak.
(laughs)
- [Oak] Me.
- That's amazing. Okay, so
who does an amazing impersonation in song?
- I can tell you that we
did two separate Ham4Ham's
where Oak sang as Minnie Mouse.
- Oh you sing like Minnie Mouse?
- I sang as Mickey singing as, um,
why is her name escaping me?
Wicked.
Idina Menzel.
Idina Menzel!
Or Adele Dazeem.
- It's a very specific impression.
- Now I'm gonna need to hear this.
- [Christopher] Do it, Oak. Do it, Oak.
- I'm gonna need to hear this.
I want to hear a little.
- Oh yes!
Oh I love the exit!
(laughs)
- [Oak] Oh boy, it's
nice to meet you, Kelly!
So good to be on your show.
♪ Helpless! ♪
♪ Look into my eyes, and
the sky's the limit ♪
♪ I'm helpless! ♪
That's right!
- [Lin] That's right on Disney+.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, I
watch a lot of Mickey Mouse
and that was nailed!